okay so just just using this heel toe
knee step heel toe knee step okay and as
you get better at it once you get deeper
and deeper anything I want you to remain
as erect as possible as well so very
erect and then I want you to take that
don't use your arms yet it's worth been
all fluidity
so it's hard to come back up once that
foot steps
so
right basically this is
[Music]
you do that maneuver all the time in in
your eye dog step right so in your
shintai right I step and then I step up
it's exactly the same okay
but you have to get it deeper so as you
keep working my heel toe knee look for
my knees is it in between and then when
my leg comes around it's going to go
behind him as I should go in it's behind
him you see and then this is where I can
drive and I'm going to keep going
deeper
to go deeper dry okay try it again
so the same thing if he's if he's
resisting just resist resist heart okay
uh I if I try to do this without the
ground pop it's very hard but when I get
the Dropbox it's very easy to do
I have to have the ground path on the
chico
so if I go here like it's kind of bounce
off of that as you can see you guys
feeling that okay so I as you're going
through
ground
[Music]
and then you have your adhesion
because you're not supposed to slide up
into the guillotine
and then I come here like this I'm not
going to slide on his body
here at that hip joint so proud and I'm
in here and here
and you guys see that it'll slide all
the way up so
okay let's go
okay uh once you get there
you're going to start capping his legs
it has more to do with what his energy
is but because he's we haven't
prescribed it no energy I'll just cap
and I'll cap
and I just drive drive until I get him
down so you drive fast and far enough to
get his line of gravity outside his base
of support and then you stay connected
to him uh
if you stay connected to him you're
trying not to get put in guard so you're
seeking side control is usually what
comes up okay so I doing the same foot
Maneuvers I now added the cap I start to
drive
and I find my side control
get no energy on him
foreign
[Music]
okay so on the outside leg my my main
goal on the capping is that I don't let
that thing hook inside so my main goal
is to make sure it goes outside
we don't prematurely pick it up way for
him to start teetering and as his leg
comes up just like your testibility I
just leave it outside of that book okay
I don't pick it up so I'm doing my
maneuver up I'm not going to pick it up
I drive and this is where I just leave
it outside that leg
oh
on the other leg
that's key so sometimes you get too high
on the glute area and you start to dry
well you can step out widen your base
you see
the goal there is that I don't let him
put his face of support back under his
line of gravity so it can't be on the
glute or especially for a static eye or
just under the glute because he can
still widen his face so I kind of go
here and I monitor what he's doing so as
I push and I feel him step it says I'm
gonna be here I'm not going to come up
here I just do this cap and I keep
driving
without kicking his legs up
dry
and stay stuck to him
okay let's try it again understand the
two caps go
all right so uh we'll work from the
clinch to start out with okay and we're
gonna do the pop so I'm gonna pop him up
pop and drop so I pop drop walk in
everything's the same
walk
clear
pop
let's go
[Music]
so he drives this time when I take the
wind and turns right and maybe I'm
trying to shove him down to a knee so he
pops back up and there's this again
so if you drive I turn up and before he
gets that before you feel me start to
pull you down you're going to resist and
try to get the hell back out of it
he pushes I turn that's the key right
there
again so you see what I was trying to do
he pushes I turn boom I'm trying to do
this
he pushes he feels that head pull he
goes up I let it go up and I go right
into
the takedown
Okay so
don't forget as you take someone to
confuse you depend on their skill though
vapor lock you'll get the knee kick in
there so go slow today remember I'll try
to resist the head crack down and then
you let it up and you follow it in
here we go
[Music]